[Music]
Amber Rose reveals she's having breast
reduction surgery she wants to downsize
so she got more free time running around
and were there t-shirts and so we're
looking forward to this one it's
spaghetti shots I'm really excited about
the model shared the news on Instagram
stories on Tuesday that she was
undergoing surgery on Wednesday in a
second photo she opened up about her
feelings writing quote I'm really scared
and really excited at the same time the
decision to have a breast reduction has
long been in the works for the mother of
one my boobs dad I'm not perfect and you
know I'm just very blunt open about all
those things because I'm a natural girl
I'm a human being in July 2017 the star
shared on Instagram that she had been
thinking about getting a reduction and
while she waited until 2018 to have the
surgery she said she wanted the
procedure because quote my boobs are
stupid heavy my back hurts
and I can't wear cute little shirts
without a grandma bra et caught up with
rose in 2015 where she opened up about
her body and embracing imperfection I
feel like you know we definitely have to
be yourself don't try to fit into
society it's okay for you to be a sexual
being you shouldn't feel bad for your
sexuality who you are as a person
[Music]